.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Christine Bolt
kämpft mit allen Mitteln.
Das muss reichen.
Sie muss eine Institution der Schweiz
retten: die St. Galler Olma.
Ich habe ein Parfüm
für spezielle Momente.
Das hilft mir, mich zu fokussieren.
Die grösste Publikumsmesse
steht auf dem Spiel -
dort,
wo sich sonst Jahr für Jahr
die Bundesrätinnen und Bundesräte mit
einem Schweinchen ablichten lassen.
Die Olma gilt als Leuchtturm
für die Ostschweiz.
Jeden Herbst
flanieren über 300'000 Menschen
während elf Tagen von Stand zu Stand.
Nun steht der gesamte Messebetrieb
wegen Corona
in finanzieller Schieflage.
Es droht die Pleite.
* Düstere Klänge *
Es fehlen uns 30 Mio. Fr.
aus der Geschäftstätigkeit.
Und der Bau wurde noch teurer.
Aus der Coronazeit
fehlen uns 40 Mio. Fr.
Die Olma ist nicht systemrelevant.
Das ist
keine klassische Staatsaufgabe.
Man kann nicht immer betteln.
Jetzt ist fertig.
Wir geben noch mal etwas,
aber dann muss es selber stehen.
Es ist April.
Ich bin das erste Mal
mit Christine Bolt unterwegs.
Ich begleite sie
auf ihrem Kampf um die Millionen.
Bis im Oktober
will sie die Olma gerettet haben.
... National- und Ständeräte ...
Ich begrüsse die anwesenden
Nationalrätinnen und -räte,
diverse Mitglieder
von kantonalen Parlamenten,
stellvertretend
für den St. Galler Kantonsrat ...
Die 47-Jährige und der Verwaltungsrat
haben
einen ambitionierten Rettungsplan
mit drei grossen Etappenzielen:
die Genossenschaft
in eine AG wandeln,
eine Finanzspritze der Politik
und Millionen
mit Sponsoren und Fanaktien sammeln.
Hofft man bei
solchen öffentlichen Anlässen,
dass man irgendwann
den grossen Geldgeber findet?
Die Hoffnung gebe ich nie auf.
Ich hoffe auf Vertrauen
und dass die Lust da ist ...
Dass die, die noch nicht unter-
schrieben haben, unterschreiben.
Und dass sie das weitererzählen.
Und wenn sich
ein grosser Geldgeber findet,
ist das auch nicht schlecht.
Wo müssen wir durch? Gut.
Voilà.
Woah.
Cool.
Wir sind an der Frühlingsmesse OFFA.
Bereits hier will sie
aus der Not eine Tugend machen.
Die OFFA ist die frischere
und unkompliziertere Messe.
Weniger formal.
Wir haben bewusst
bunte Menschen eingeladen:
mehr Frauen, mehr Junge.
Das Motto ist Magenta, also nicht
nur graue, alte, weisse Männer
in schwarz-weiss und grau-weiss.
- Wow, das sagst du so.
Ich sage fast alles.
Nein, nicht so, aber schon ...
Wir wollen ja zeitgemäss,
modern und bei den Leuten sein.
Dass die Durchmischung des Publikums
anders ist.
Stefan, hoi. Herzlich willkommen.
- Christine, hoi. Hoi, hoi.
Auf Du und Du begrüssen sich hier
Wirtschafts- und Politprominente.
Ich höre, wie sich Christine Bolt
mit der einen oder dem anderen
gleich
für ein Geschäftsmeeting verabredet.
An der Seite der Olma-Direktorin:
ein langjähriges
Geschäftsleitungsmitglied.
Wie unterscheidet sich Christine Bolt
von den Vorgängern?
Sie ist natürlich die erste Frau.
Und es ist
eine andere Generation am Ruder.
Früher war der Olma-Direktor
ein gestandener, älterer Herr.
Im Laufe der Zeit waren auch immer
wieder andere Schwerpunkte wichtig.
Mit Christine haben wir jemanden,
der sehr nahe am Markt ist
und auch
einen Marketinghintergrund hat.
Sie ist auch im Denken sehr heutig
und weiss,
was die Zielgruppen wollen.
Für uns, wo es um Produkte geht,
ist das sehr wichtig.
* Applaus *
(Frau)
Worauf freuen Sie sich besonders?
Das ist immer eine schwierige Frage.
Ganz ehrlich:
auf Halle 4/5 mit Freundinnen.
Ich freue mich
auf fünf Tage gute Stimmung,
darauf, Neues zu entdecken
und auf etwas Leichtigkeit.
Das sind die Momente,
wo ich merke, warum wir kämpfen.
Hoi.
Hoi. Ich habe dich gesehen.
- Gratuliere.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Hoi.
- Hoi.
Ich glaube es gar nicht.
Meine erste OFFA-Eröffnung
war vor einem Jahr.
Wir haben also
gleich viele zusammen.
Also,
du als Chefin und ich als Gast.
Es ist ein Anlass. Es ist ein Fest.
Die Weibel und Fahnen
geben ihm den Charakter.
Sonst kann man
auch ein Grillfest machen.- Sicher.
Ich gehe noch zum Bankentisch.
- Ja, geh.
Er ist direkt hier.
Wenn ich denke, ich sei eine Arme
wegen meines Jobs, denke ich:
"Sergio Ermotti
hat sicher den schlimmeren."
Gut, er ist ja auch abgehärtet.
- Ja, ja. Er verdient wohl mehr.
Ich kenne die Messe
als eine grosse Gewerbeausstellung.
Vor 20 Jahren habe ich selber
einmal hier gearbeitet.
Dem Erlebnis wird heutzutage
viel mehr Beachtung geschenkt.
Das ist auch nötig,
um sich gegen die Konkurrenz
im Online-Handel zu behaupten.
Während der Messetage hat Christine
Bolt immer ein gedrängtes Programm.
Alle wollen sie sehen
und sie möchte alle begrüssen.
Man muss eigentlich sagen,
ob es 90 oder 95 ist.
Guten Morgen.
Mitarbeiterinnen versuchen,
die Olma-Volksaktie zu verkaufen -
für 1'100 Fr. pro Aktie.
Gemäss Rettungsplan sollen so
insgesamt 20 Mio. Fr. zusammenkommen.
Aus meiner Sicht
eine schier unmögliche Aufgabe.
Welche Gründe hört ihr von denen,
die keine kaufen?
Der Preis, oder?
- Der Preis, ja. Das ist es.
Ja.
- Gerade für eine Familie ...
Sie führen hier
einen Kampf um die Millionen.
Wie geht es Ihnen dabei?
- Manchmal denke ich:
"Wir sind in der schwierigsten
Phase, kommen aus einer Krise,
sind in einer Transformation
und müssen wachsen und bauen."
Und in dieser
sowieso schon strengen Zeit
müssen wir 20 Mio. Fr. suchen.
Da finde ich manchmal: "Die hätten
uns schon mehr geben können."
Wenn wir es schaffen,
haben wir eine sehr breite
Abstützung in der Region,
was uns langfristig
ein Fundament geben wird.
Christine Bolt arbeitete im Marketing
und war Leiterin des Lesermarktes
bei einem Zeitungsverlag.
Sie weiss,
wie man sich gut vermarktet,
tut dies auch
in der Medienmitteilung der Messe.
Es ist wichtig,
diese Botschaft zu transportieren:
"Das Geschäftsmodell funktioniert,
wir schreiben Gewinn."
"Wir sind zurück und wieder hier."
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir die Bedeutung zeigen.
Das können wir jetzt "beweisen".
Das ist nicht nur Geschwätz.
Würdest du
sogar im Titel so einsteigen?
In Pressetexten versucht man, das
immer knackig und gut zu verkaufen.
Versucht man da auch,
etwas zu übertreiben?
Oder es so zu verkaufen,
dass die Strategie spürbar ist?
Ich bin kein Fan von Übertreibung.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass man selbstbewusst und klar ist.
Ich mag knackige Geschichten.
Mir ist wichtig, dass das im Kontext
unserer Wachstumsstrategie steht.
Aber auch der Kapitalfindung.
Dass man das einordnet und schaut,
welche Botschaften wichtig sind
für den übergeordneten Plan.
Bis später.
- Tschüss.- Tschau.
1943 fand die erste Olma statt.
Die Versorgungsengpässe
aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg
erhöhten die Interessen
für die Landwirtschaft,
den Anbau und die Milchwirtschaft.
Produkte zur Schau stellen,
aufklären und Waren verkaufen
waren damals wie noch heute
tragende Elemente.
Auch die Tiere
gehören seit Beginn der Messe dazu.
Getragen wird die Olma
von einer Genossenschaft.
Das starke Fundament
bilden die Stadt St. Gallen
und Kantone aus der Ostschweiz.
Seit Jahren finden auf dem Olma-Areal
in den Messehallen
auch eine Frühlingsmesse,
Bildungsausstellungen
und zahlreiche Veranstaltungen
statt - gegen 130 pro Jahr.
90 Angestellte arbeiten dafür, dass
die Hallen stets ausgelastet sind.
Jahresumsatz: 30 Mio. Fr.
Und dann kam Corona.
Weil die Genossenschaft
zu einem grossen Teil von
der öffentlichen Hand getragen wird,
bekam sie
keine Härtefallgelder vom Bund.
Dieser delegierte an die Stadt
und den Kanton St. Gallen.
Wir konnten
fast zwei Jahre nicht arbeiten.
Der Bau hatte aber schon angefangen.
Unser ganzes Erspartes
war im Bau festgebunden.
Wir kamen schnell
in Liquiditätsengpässe.
Sie arbeiten gerade in der Funktion
der Retterin der Olma Messen.
Also, eigentlich nur.
Was ist mit dem Job der Direktorin?
Den mache ich auch noch,
aber das ist gerade ein Hobby.
Spass.
Gastgeberin zu sein, hier und da
eine Ansprache zu halten,
und die Unternehmung
gegen aussen zu vertreten,
die Geschäftsleitung zu führen -
diese Aufgaben hätte ich sowieso.
Ihr Arbeitspensum liege aktuell
bei 160 %, manchmal auch noch höher.
Christine. Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Zum Wohl, Urs.
Brigitte.
- Zum Wohl.- Die Damen.
Deshalb gibt es kaum Freizeit.
Heute aber trifft Christine Bolt
ihre besten Freundinnen
aus dem Toggenburg,
welche sie schon
seit über 30 Jahren kennt.
Ihr Ziel
ist die süffige Degustationshalle.
Wir wissen,
dass das ihr Arbeitsplatz ist.
In dieser Welt kennt sie Leute
und möchte mit ihnen reden.
Das ist so und das ist auch okay.
- Ist sie hier anders?
Nächste Frage.
Ein bisschen, natürlich.
Sie repräsentiert hier.
Das ist ihre Rolle.
Privat kann sie natürlich ...
... etwas mehr ...
... aus sich rauskommen.
- Ja.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass sie zwei
total verschiedene Gesichter hat.
Sie ist ...
- Wer sind Sie denn?
Auch ausserhalb ihrer Arbeitszeit
lässt sie keine Möglichkeit offen,
Geldgeber und mögliche Aktionäre
anzusprechen.
Wie geht es?
Trauen Sie sich?
- Ja.
In einer Woche die GV
und danach kann man Aktien ...
Das kommt schon.
- Super.
Patience.
- Ja, ist gut. Alles gut.
Es freut mich sehr,
dass ihr hier seid.
Tschüss. Tschau. Kannst du ...
- Was?
Geschäft abgewickelt?
- Oh mein Gott. Ja.
Natürlich.
Neben Hausi? Sein Manager.
- Diese Degustationshalle
hat ihren eigenen Zauber
und macht viele Leute redselig.
Meine Behauptung ist ja,
dass die Degustationshalle
der eigentlich grösste Magnet für
die Besucherinnen und Besucher ist
und darum viel
zum Bestehen der Messe beiträgt,
wenn nicht am meisten.
Mit Zahlen lässt sich dies
natürlich nicht belegen.
Christine, ich habe einen Auftrag.
- Jawohl?
Ich darf
zu einem Glas Wein einladen.
Ja. Wer ist es? Sieht er gut aus?
- Wer?
Sag ihm, wir seien zu dritt hier.
Das Spezielle an diesem Job
ist, dass man viel Wertschätzung,
aber auch
verdammt viel Kritik kriegt.
Jeder weiss ...
Ich denke immer: "Hoffentlich hat
das 'Tagblatt' nichts geschrieben."
Man ist ...
- Liest du alle Berichte über dich?
Nein. Das "Tagblatt" lese ich,
aber sonst nichts.
Kommentare auf Social Media
lese ich nicht.
Meine Kinder sagen immer:
"Christine ist in der Zeitung."
Wir sind immer wieder gefordert
in Diskussionen mit ihr.
Sie ist so taff
und denkt so schnell.
Das fordert uns.
Und sie ist auch sehr ungeduldig.
Also, mit Leuten,
die langsamer denken -
nicht mit uns -,
ist sie sehr ungeduldig.
Das Image der Olma Messen
hat gelitten.
Nicht wegen Corona,
sondern weil die öffentliche Hand die
Olma mit Finanzspritzen retten muss.
Nach der Festlaune kommt der Kater.
Zwei Monate später
geht es im Kantonsrat
wieder um Geld
und wieder um die Olma.
Der Grüne-Politiker Thomas Schwager
möchte einen Riegel schieben.
Es wird zu einem Fass ohne Boden.
Darum ist jetzt der richtige
Zeitpunkt, um dafür zu sorgen,
dass der Kanton St. Gallen nicht
noch mehr Geld in das Loch wirft.
Schon wenige Monate zuvor
ging es um Steuergeld:
Ein 8,6-Mio.-Fr.-Darlehen
soll in Eigenkapital der Olma
gewandelt werden.
Heute geht es
um den Gastkanton an der Olma.
Das Tessin hat für 2024 abgesagt -
aus Spargründen.
Nun schlägt die St. Galler Regierung
vor,
mit dem eigenen Kanton
in die Bresche zu springen.
Kostenpunkt: 1,2 Mio. Fr.
Einige sehen darin
eine versteckte Subvention oder
Sinnlosigkeit, andere eine Chance.
Hätten wir die Richtlinien
immer schwarz-weiss ausgelegt,
hätten verschiedene Gesuche
nicht bewilligt werden können.
Diese Lotterie
verbietet einen Spielraum,
auch mit den Richtlinien,
die wir haben.
Wir sind wenige Monate
nach der Diskussion im Februar
wieder am gleichen Ort: Es soll noch
mal 1 Mio. Fr. gesprochen werden.
Irgendwann ist der Zapfen ab.
Irgendwann muss die Olma
sich selber finanzieren können
und selber verantworten,
dass das Geld reinkommt,
das sie
für ihre Investitionen brauchen.
Wieder sagte das Parlament Ja
und stimmte zu,
dass der Heimkanton St. Gallen
an der Olma
Werbung für sich selber macht.
Zudem kann die Olma
17 Mio. Fr. Darlehen von Stadt
und Kanton in Eigenkapital wandeln.
Ein erstes Etappenziel ist geschafft.
Kantonsrat Thomas Schwager
bleibt kritisch.
Die Halle ist zwei Nummern zu gross
für die Stadt St. Gallen.
Sie ist sehr teuer, und um das
rentabel betreiben zu können,
braucht es
eine supergute Auslastung.
Und ich bin einfach nicht sicher,
ob der Businessplan,
den die Olma Messen uns in der vor-
beratenden Kommission vorgelegt hat,
wirklich tragfähig ist.
Ob wir es wirklich hinkriegen,
ab 2025 bis zu 24 Anlässe pro Jahr
machen zu können,
mit Comedy, mit Konzerten,
ob St. Gallen jener Ort ist,
wohin die Leute strömen
und die Hallen füllen.
Es hat mich geärgert,
dass gewisse Leute
die Bühne für ihre
politische Karriere genutzt haben.
Wir können nichts für unsere
finanziellen Herausforderungen.
Mein Team,
der Verwaltungsrat und ich,
setzen Tag und Nacht alles daran,
dass die Olma Messen
für die Ostschweiz überleben.
Da wünschte ich mir
mehr Unterstützung.
Wir machen das nicht für uns,
sondern für die Ostschweiz.
Das neue Prestigeobjekt: die Halle 1.
Sie ist doppelt so gross
wie die grösste bestehende Halle,
mit einer Fläche so gross
wie eineinhalb Fussballfelder.
Kostenpunkt: 180 Mio. Fr.
- Ich würde gerne hier reinspringen.
Aber ich brauche die Hose
für das Referat heute Abend.
Die Halle ist riesig.
Viel grösser als alle anderen Hallen,
die Sie haben.
Ist das der Grössenwahn der Olma?
Nein, das war einfach
ein mutiger Entscheid.
Es ist sicher sehr gross
für die Ostschweiz.
Aber wenn man
etwas Grosses erreichen möchte,
ist es gut, gross was zu wagen.
- Ist es nicht der falsche Zeitpunkt?
Das war nicht die Frage.
Man entschied vor zehn Jahren,
das zu machen.
Vor sechs Jahren sagte das Volk Ja.
Covid war eine Zäsur und es
gab Veränderungen auf dem Markt.
Aber wir haben eine sehr grosse
Nachfrage nach Messen und Events.
Hallo. Ni hao.
Ich kenne
nicht alle persönlich mit Namen.
Ni hao.
Wegen dieses Dachs prasselt weitere
Kritik auf Christine Bolt ein.
Der Auftrag
geht in einen anderen Kontinent:
Eine chinesische Firma
konstruiert das Dach.
Über 20 Chinesen arbeiten
während Monaten in St. Gallen.
Kein Schweizer
arbeitet mit dem System.
Wir fragten viele an,
ob sie mit dem Systemarbeiter
kooperieren würden.
Leider sagten alle ab.
Von den zehn,
die es auf der Welt gibt,
offerierten nur drei:
zwei Europäer und ein Chinese.
Die Europäer
waren 3 Mio. und 6 Mio. Fr. teurer
und konnten uns nicht zusichern,
überhaupt Stahl liefern zu können.
Wegen der Krise in der Ukraine,
Weissrussland.
Der Chinese gab uns
einen fixen, günstigeren Preis
und fixe Lieferungszeiten.
Wir entschieden, dass uns
die Zuverlässigkeit wichtiger ist,
um den Bau fertigstellen
und die Halle
rechtzeitig bewirten zu können.
Das Besondere am Dach: Es ist
über die ganze Fläche stützenfrei
und an vielen Hängepunkten
stark belastbar.
Die offizielle Halleneröffnung
ist im Frühling.
Sofern es
keine Überraschungen mehr gibt,
stellen hier bereits an der Olma
die ersten Aussteller aus.
Stell dir die Olma vor: Da ist
Erlebnis Nahrung, der Regiomarkt,
alle Essens- und Getränkestände -
alles auf einem Platz.
Megacool.
Der wichtigste Tag des Jahres
steht an.
Genossenschafterinnen
und Genossenschafter
entscheiden
über das Rechtskleid der Olma Messen.
Entstehen soll eine Aktien-
gesellschaft mit der Möglichkeit,
mehr Fremdkapital aufzunehmen.
Dies ist der Grundstein
für den angedachten Rettungsplan
aus der Misere.
Ich hoffe, es geht gut.
Grundsätzlich ist es
aber mehr Vorfreude als Respekt.
Mein Leitmotto:
"Jeder Scheiss hat eine Chance."
Ich habe das Glück,
viel Energie
und viel Zuversicht zu haben.
Mich bringt so schnell
nichts aus der Ruhe.
Es ist heiss.
Wenn es heute ein Nein gibt,
sind wir auf Feld 1.
Es ist schon ein grosser Tag.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Wir haben ein Coronaloch
von ungefähr 30 Mio. Fr.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
* Applaus *
Du, jetzt bist du eine AG.
Jetzt sind wir eine AG - ab jetzt.
Hach! Ja.
Ist der Druck jetzt weg
oder steigt der jetzt?
Was soll ich sagen? Machen wir so?
Genau.
Was sollen wir sagen?
Es ist wie beim Wandern: Man ist auf
einem Gipfel und findet das geil.
Aber es kommen noch fünf mehr.
Aber es ist
eine grosse Erleichterung,
v.a., weil es einstimmig war.
Das ist ein
unglaublicher Vertrauensbeweis.
Ich habe kurz überlegt,
was wir letztes Jahr gemacht haben:
Jede Sitzung, jede Fahrt,
jedes Referat hat sich gelohnt.
Es war ein langer,
anstrengender Weg.
Aber das ist eine schöne
Wertschätzung und gibt Vertrauen.
Die Olma ist über dem Berg.
Aber es kommt noch einer.
- Es hat noch einen.
Genau.
Die Olma ist über dem ersten Berg.
Aber es kommt
noch ein zweiter und ein dritter.
Aber wir wandern ja gerne. Geil.
Super.
Zum Wohl. Wow!
- Zum Wohl.
Zack, sind wir eine AG.
Cheers. Zum Wohl. Danke vielmals.
Wir haben jetzt
10 Mio. Fr. Aktienkapital zusammen.
Die Genossenschaft wurde ohne
Gegenstimmen in eine AG umgewandelt.
Und wir sind vor anderthalb Jahren
operativ wieder sehr gut gestartet.
Wir sind jetzt gut unterwegs
und an einem guten Zwischenpunkt.
Oje!
Bolt ist eine, die den Hobel ansetzt.
Und wo gehobelt wird, fallen Späne.
In diesem Fall sind es Menschen,
die intern umplatziert
oder degradiert werden.
Mitte Mai verkündet sie
grosse Änderungen im Organigramm.
Die Reaktionen
werden sehr gemischt sein.
Manche werden schnell merken,
worum es geht,
andere werden länger brauchen.
Für gewisse wird es ...
Denen wird es egal sein
und andere werden wütend werden.
Was machen Sie mit denen,
die wütend werden?- Machen lassen.
Das ist ihre Geschichte.
Ich bin da, wenn sie reden wollen.
Es ist nicht Aufgabe
der Geschäftsleitung,
Menschen glücklich zu machen,
sondern das Unternehmen zu führen,
damit sich die Menschen
bei der Arbeit wohlfühlen.
Es kommt halt vor, dass man mal auch
unpopuläre Entscheide treffen muss.
Bolt will nicht, dass wir
sie hier filmen - zu heikel.
Sie sagte mir aber später,
dass fünf bis zehn Personen
der insgesamt 90 Mitarbeiter
gekündigt haben
oder sich nach neuen Jobs umschauen.
Die Olma-Direktorin
ist beliebt als Referentin,
bekannt in der ganzen Ostschweiz.
Deshalb
wurde Christine Bolt angefragt
für eine 1.-August-Rede
in Appenzell auf dem Kronberg.
Treffpunkt morgens um 5 Uhr.
Mit dabei: Patenkind,
Schwester, Mutter und Ehemann.
Gehen wir noch hier rein?
- Nein, wir gehen da rauf.
Nein. Schatz, nicht in die Beiz.
Mein Mann ist schon in der Beiz.
Nein, es ist nicht hier.
Es ist draussen.- Wo?
Nein, wir müssen rauf. Ja.
Du bist ein Armer.
Du kannst nachher rein.
Auch auf dem Berg
sind die Zeiten stürmisch.
* Sanfte Alphornklänge *
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Heute, am 1. August, geht die Sonne
in Appenzell und St. Gallen
genau 4 Min. früher auf
als in Zürich,
7 Min. früher als in Basel,
9 Min. früher als in Bern
und geschlagene 17 Min. früher
als in Genf.
Liebe Gäste,
wir sind der Zeit voraus.
Nicht nur heute, sondern jeden Tag,
und schon immer.
Nach dem offiziellen Teil
reist der 73-jährige Ehemann Peter
voraus ins Ferienhaus
in Bolts alter Heimat Wildhaus.
Die Damen nehmen den Weg zu Fuss.
So.
Schön.
Ich weiss nicht, was ihr habt.
Ich halte es offen für euch.
- Danke.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich zittere.
Das nennt sich doch Knieschlottern
oder so.
Sie haben es so gut
mit Ihrem Gottenkind.
Waren eigene Kinder
auch mal ein Thema?- Nein, nie.
Ich mag Kinder sehr gerne,
wollte aber
nie die Mutterrolle einnehmen.
Ich wusste, dass meine
drei Schwestern Kinder haben werden.
Ich habe einen Clan.
Mir war die Arbeit immer wichtig.
Ich wollte mich
darauf konzentrieren.
Als meine Schwestern solche Gören
kriegten, löschte es mir direkt ab.
Aufgewachsen in Wildhaus und einst
Tourismusdirektorin im Toggenburg
zieht es Christine Bolt
oft zurück zu ihren Wurzeln.
Sie hält hier mit den Schwestern
eine Zweitwohnung
für Sommerferien und zum Skifahren.
Das ist fast dort,
wo wir aufgewachsen sind.
Unser Elternhaus steht nicht mehr.
Aber vom Flair her
ist es sehr ähnlich.
Man kann sich hier treffen.
Das ist der Familienhauptpunkt.
Das ist mir sehr wichtig.
Prost.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Jetzt geht es viel besser.
- Jetzt geht es super.
Ich könnte nicht mehr hier leben.
Es wäre mir zu engstirnig.
Ich bin durchaus sehr urban -
im Geist und in der Haltung,
in meiner Einstellung.
Aber mit den Füssen am Boden.
Ich weiss,
wie sich die Landbevölkerung fühlt
und konnte die Nähe behalten.
Darum habe ich
so eine moderne Lavalampe.
Die ist lustig.
Es sind ein bisschen viele, Schatz.
Mit Ehemann Peter
ist sie seit zwölf Jahren zusammen,
seit vier Jahren verheiratet.
Mir ist heute aufgefallen,
dass Sie Ihren Mann
oft und schnell vorstellen,
wenn Sie irgendwo sind.
- Ja.
Warum ist das so? Damit es
keine Missverständnisse gibt?
Gab es das schon?
Mir ist es wichtig,
dass die Leute wissen,
dass Peter mein Mann ist.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass er viel dabei ist.
Man sieht: Wir haben
einen grossen Altersunterschied.
Es dachten auch schon Leute,
er sei mein Vater.
Logisch, er ist
zwei Jahre jünger als mein Vater
und zwei Jahre älter
als meine Mutter.
Aber ich würde das auch machen,
wenn wir gleich alt wären.
Anfangs war das schon komisch,
aber wir haben uns daran gewöhnt.
So ist das jetzt bei uns.
Wir haben das diskutiert,
als wir zusammenkamen.
Mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen.
Wir wussten,
worauf wir uns einlassen.- Ja.
Was sind die Vor- und Nachteile?
Ein Vorteil ist, dass ich ...
... der ruhende Pol bin.
Ich habe das hinter mir.
Also, in dem Sinne,
dass ich nicht mehr in einem Stress
oder einer Fremdbestimmung drin bin.
Das ist ein Vorteil.
So kann Christine Dinge abladen,
die sie sonst nirgends abladen kann.
Er ist ein wichtiger Teil
des Ganzen.
Dadurch kann ich viel aushalten.
Brauchen Sie den ruhenden Pol?
- Ja, den brauche ich.
Und diese Sicherheit und Nestwärme.
Und einfach diesen Halt.
Das ist extrem wichtig für mich.
Danke. Hey, merci vielmals.
Merci vielmals für heute Morgen.
Merci.
My love.
Ich weiss nicht.
Du hast das gemacht.
Mitte August bekommt
die neue Olma-Halle 1 einen Namen.
Dank dieses Sponsoringvertrags
spült es gutes Geld
in die Olma-Kasse.
Wie viel bleibt geheim.
Ist das der grosse Befreiungsschlag?
Es ist ein weiterer grosser Schritt
auf unserem langen Weg.
Befreiungsschlag
wäre zu hoch gegriffen.
Das ist sehr wichtig für uns -
finanziell,
aber auch als Zeichen gegen aussen:
"Wir haben es geschafft."
"Wir haben einen Partner,
der zu uns passt und zu uns steht."
Das gibt uns Aufwind.
Ein starker strategischer Schachzug,
denn jetzt ist die Kreditgeberin
St. Galler Kantonalbank
noch stärker an die Olma gebunden.
Ist es ein beruhigendes Gefühl,
an der Seite der St. Galler
Kantonalbank gehen zu können
und zu wissen,
dass sie Staatsgarantie mitbringt?
Uns verbindet
eine lange Partnerschaft.
Wir wissen schon seit jeher, dass
wir uns auf sie verlassen können.
Das gibt einem
ein sehr gutes Gefühl.
Die Verkündigung hat Strahlkraft.
Trotz der Geldprobleme:
Für die anderen Hallen komme
ein Namenssponsoring nicht infrage,
versicherte mir Bolt.
Sie sind in der FDP,
der Gastkanton St. Gallen
ist aufgegleist
von einem FDP-Regierungsrat,
in der Kantonalbank sitzt
ein FDP-Kollege im Verwaltungsrat,
Halle 1 wurde
auch von einem FDPler gebaut -
die kennen Sie natürlich alle.
Der Verwaltungsrat der Olma
ist auch ein FDPler
und ehemaliger Stadtpräsident.
Gelang die Rettung
dank des Politfilzes?
Ich würde das nicht Filz nennen,
wir kennen uns einfach alle.
Ich kenne aber viele Politiker
aus anderen Parteien.
Auch dann wäre es gelungen.
Hier kommen Menschen zusammen,
die sich
für den Standort Ostschweiz und
die regionale Wirtschaft einsetzen.
Und dieselbe Partei.
Ich bin politisch nicht mehr aktiv.
Ich bin in der Partei,
aber ohne Amt,
weil ich unabhängig sein wollte.
Ich engagiere mich
für die Olma Messen St. Gallen.
Christine Bolt hätte im Spätsommer
die Möglichkeit gehabt,
selber für die FDP
in den Kantonsrat nachzurücken.
Sie lehnte ab.
Ihre Mission habe Priorität.
Es ist Ende September.
Nur noch wenige Tage bis zur Olma.
Die ersten Messestände in
der neuen Halle werden aufgestellt.
Was hast du?
- Da hinten ist der Stand.
Weber, g'nuss macht.
- Genau, das ist er mit dem Turm.
Und ...
- Wann kommen die Elemente?
Am Freitag oder nächste Woche.
- Mit den Ausstellern.
Es ist ein weiterer Berg.
Da mussten
viele Zahnräder zusammenpassen.
Es geht gerade auf,
der Bau und der Betrieb.
Damit das möglich ist,
haben viele Leute von uns
und vom Bau zusammengearbeitet.
Es bleibt spannend,
aber wir schaffen es.
Eine weitere Hürde ist geschafft.
- Wie oft haben Sie Blut geschwitzt,
bis die Halle
in Betrieb genommen wird?
Nie.
Ich wusste immer, dass es klappt.
Ungebremste Zuversicht
und viel Optimismus.
So habe ich Christine Bolt
die letzten Monate erlebt.
Geht nicht, gibt's nicht,
auch wenn es oft
ein Balanceakt war.
So. Das sind unsere neuen Büros.
Sieht schön aus:
hell, freundlich ...
Wir haben diesen langen Weg gesehen,
Sie brauchten viel Energie,
auch um diese Millionen Franken
zu sammeln. Was haben Sie erreicht?
Wir haben schon ziemlich viel Geld
zusammengebracht.
27 Mio. Fr. haben wir.
Ein Teil kommt noch
aus der Geschäftstätigkeit.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch 10 Mio. Fr.
Fast drei Viertel haben wir.
Aber die letzten 25 %
werden noch mal anstrengend.
Aber wir haben einiges erreicht
im letzten Jahr.
Zur Rettungsmission
droht weiteres Ungemach:
Eine Messehalle, die Halle 9,
muss
wegen dem Ausbau des Autobahntunnels
unterbaut
oder gar abgebrochen werden.
Dies stellt die Olma innen und aussen
nochmals komplett auf den Kopf.
Diese dritte Röhre bedeutet
ein Teilabbruch der Halle,
evtl. der ganzen Halle,
und dann müsste man sie neu bauen.
Sie werden nie mehr eine normale
Olma-Direktorin, sondern Bauchefin.
Ich wollte noch nie normal sein.
Ich bin nicht mehr im Krisenmodus,
sondern im Transformationsmodus,
im Wachstumsmodus.
Das ist wie im Leben: Es geht immer
weiter, mit neuen Herausforderungen.
Für die erste Olma-Direktorin
ist die Rettung der Olma
wie eine Bergtour
in ihrer Toggenburger Heimat:
Mal geht es hoch und dann
auch wieder ein paar Schritte runter.
Aber mein Eindruck ist:
Sie ist mit sicherem Schritt
und guten Mutes unterwegs.